you ever see people when they hit a
certain age they act a little weird it's
almost like you don't know what's going
on but they got Panic anxiety they're
they're like a little bit more fidgety
their temper is a little bit off what is
the matter with you by the way all of
this is one number and I'm going to give
you what that one number is it's one
magical number that sometimes messes
with people said so let me get right
into it by the way if this video gives
you value give it a thumbs up and
subscribe at the end of the video let me
get right into it my dad
for the longest time he drove a 1978
Mercedes 240D it's a diesel he drove and
he would tell everybody all the time the
moment this engine dies I'm gonna die
we're going down together it's gonna go
over a half a million miles it's a
diesel Patrick you always got to buy
diesel this guy was team diesel right
so one day I get a call and my sister
says you know the diesel shut down the
middle industry I said what so I call my
Dad what's going on Diesel's gone the
engine completely kaput gone right but
the moment that happens my dad starts
thinking he's also about to be gone go
straight to the hospital heart issues
one month stays in the hospital because
he thought he was that was the end of it
for him
and I'm sitting there talking to him I
said man you had really convinced
yourself that the expiration of this
engine was the expiration of use as well
you know we've been together for this I
said but then it's an engine it's a
different story now watch this here's
what's crazy about it years ago when my
dad had a heart attack in 94 and they
did an open heart surgery the guy had
done six angios six angioplastics three
stents in his heart fifty percent of his
heart is black the doctor said you're
lucky if you live 20 years most likely
10 to 20 years you're going to be living
anyways he lived 280 the only person
that made it to 80 in his life what's
the moral of the story
our imagination is so powerful that it
gets us to think things and create
things that are non-existent this could
be a good thing and a bad thing but most
of the time we use our imagination in a
bad way so I promised you the number
what is that magical number that messes
with people you ready it's the number
nine why nine here's why nine 29 years
old you're about to be 30. that messes
with people's head you start thinking oh
my God my friends are married they have
kids I don't have any kids I'm never
what am I going to do I'm behind the
eight ball though oh my God this is
crazy I have to figure things out of
harm screw this whole thing up so that
number nine 39 Oh my gosh I'm 39 years
old I thought I would have been a
millionaire by now because oh this is
crazy what am I I'm about to be 40 years
old
don't give me the four I'm gonna be 40.
I don't want to be 40 I'm 49 years old
oh my gosh I'm gonna be 50 half a
century half a century years old what am
I going to do 59 60 I'm not ready for
retirement 69 70. oh my gosh that 9
messes with all of our heads because it
produces two feelings either one feeling
it produces is helpless oh my gosh it's
the end of the world whoa me oh my
goodness there's nothing I can do about
it you act helpless or number two it
ought to produce a ton of urgency where
it's like you know what I gotta get
after it I got to do something about it
there's no way in the world the next
nine I'm gonna be in a position that I'm
at right now so helpless
urgency at the end of the day you can
look at it and say
hey it's just another number right it's
just another number it's number nine or
you can say it's the end of the word the
home world the story is this when you
hit that age whether it's your kid
whether it's your spouse whether it's
your friend whether it's one of your
employees whether it's yourself you have
to be aware it is just another number
but you do have to be a little bit more
urgent to make sure that the next nine
you're way ahead than you thought you
were going to be because that level of
urgency got you to your goals makes
sense so don't let number nine scare you
let it drive you more than scare you
anyways if you got value from this
message here give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I got another video I want
you to watch it's a speech I gave seven
eight months ago I believe it was in
Vegas or Palm Springs and it's a message
about will or want if you've never
watched this video before click here to
watch it take care everybody
foreign
[Music]